[Applaudissements]
beaucoup voix qui porte
il paraît merci merci j'ai envie non
merci il n'a pas il aime pas du tout
contre lui si vous voulez d'énerver
vouligny ça si vous le croisez un jour
dans la rue
voilà tous les autres one et jean-michel
bernard eu fini tu t'es sympa n'entend
pas et ça ça le rend fou un fait lui
annonce qui a dicté on vole un qui dit
grosse voix gros kick et donc c'est bien
que j'aie une petite voix ça me vexe
hommage aux drames et s'attaque à nages
exactement le seul mec à son aise qui
encore préoccupé par ça il en est le
témoin plus gros que toi non mais c'est
vrai eva est est un cri comme si vous
étiez frayer il avait une voix qui
portent pas par contre c'est un
excellent comédien